mais je suis dans la merde
en ou 2018 l'artiste l'albarine levier
le premier francophone la saskatchewan a
remporté le festival international de la
chanson de granby une victoire pour le
france ascquois à l'accent bien
particulier mais un peu aussi pour
l'ensemble des artistes francophones de
l'ouest canadien le québec le plus gros
marché musical francophone au pays
semble de plus en plus tendre l'oreille
aux sons venus d'ailleurs au canada
je pense que le fait que ont su ici au
québec beaucoup moins focus et sur la
souveraineté faire en sorte que ont une
plus grande ouverture vers les autres
artistes comme daniel lavoie du manitoba
où le groupe france ascquois hart rouge
ont bien sûr déjà réussi dans les années
1980 cet exploit de séduire ce grand
marché francophone
mais cette réelle ouverture à la
différence s'est faite de façon marquée
il ya une dizaine d'années grâce à une
pac d'artistes acadiens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que ce sont celles qui
a fait en sorte que le reste du canada
quant à l'idée si je peux dire et et ça
a beaucoup
décomplexés les jeunes artistes
francophones qu'elle a dit bien des
artistes venus de l'ouest ont alors pu
profiter de cette place offerte sous les
projecteurs québécois et ce malgré le
prix fort à payer pour un artiste de la
saskatchewan pour se déplacer à montréal
c'est un prix de fer montréal par guitry
ou même plus factice et c'est normal
qu'ils aient un peu de sport pitié sans
musique action il n'y a plus beaucoup de
projets qui a répondu ce jour non plus
faut le reconnaître on a des échéanciers
nous aussi où il faut qu'on en aura dans
les critères demandés ne s'est pas
laissée passer parce que tu joues tu
viennes la saskatchewan ses distances
sont toutefois franchi plus facilement
grâce à la venue des plateformes
d'écouté en continu
si à travers les artistes que la
population québécoise va commencer à
savoir qu'on existe pas juste comme
artiste mais comme comme communauté
mais pour bien les connaître encore
faut-il savoir où se trouvent ces
artistes un défi qu'a dû relever
l'animatrice et productrice montréalaise
france beaudoin ou son édition spéciale
dans direct de l'univers saluant la
francophonie canadienne
on découvrait des genres fantastique
mais fallait qu'on cherche donc on s'est
aperçu que l'on connaissait pas tout à
ce qui se faisait dans l'ouest du pays
on était près de mon père de charles
jeunes qui est un bois aujourd'hui fait
deux fois qu'il vient à lui si on lui
karim ans
un vent de fierté venus de l'ouest
je pense que ce qu'on amène en ce moment
c'est une soir de se renouveler une
montrer au reste du canada qu'on est
capable de faire aussi bien que les
québécois les européennes
à l'heure où les communautés
francophones hors québec ne demande qu'à
se faire entendre ici heureusement telle
radio canada à regina
[Musique]
tous